on Thursday it was revealed Queen  Elizabeth the second and Prince Philip  are now well enough to resume their  Christmas travel plans after all it was  announced Wednesday the royal couple had  canceled their plans Buckingham Palace  said in a statement quote the Queen and  the Duke of Edinburgh have heavy colds  and so have decided not to travel to  Sandringham today the queen who recently  celebrated her 90th birthday is  currently the world's longest reigning  living monarch she is still scheduled to  address the nation on her annual  Christmas Day speech on Sunday this news  comes after it was announced Tuesday  that the queen is stepping down as  patron of 25 organisations in order to  reduce her workload she'll be handing  over her patronage of certain groups to  other members of the royal family  including her grandson's Prince Harry  and Prince William and to Kate Middleton  currently the queen is royal patron of  more than 600 organizations  you